I got one more
see now this is like a Sophie's choice
of Horror you've put me in this position
Chris why do you love Halloween oh my
God first of all Halloween is the best
holiday of the year
it involves no relatives
it is the stress-free holiday
I generally get my decorations on in
September
you know Party City's always got the the
costumes out they're out in August
there's no competition Halloween is the
best holiday because
it's it's such low stress in addition it
is an excuse to revisit every horror
film that you love and it's also when
the studios say hey have we got some
horror films we should release them in
October but now it's like I feel like
that calendar has been pushed into
September for me it's more than a
month-long celebration so I love
Halloween
um
yeah I don't dress up as much as I used
to I used to dress up but no I the the
holiday is is great because it's sort of
top of mind for everybody of like oh
yeah that's I'm gonna go see the new
whatever horror film
but yeah absolutely my favorite personal
holiday what was your costume of choice
oh man
um let's see I once dressed as Luke
Skywalker from Return of the Jedi in
high school
that was in my senior year in my junior
year
I dressed as Alex from Clockwork Orange
I literally had the white jock strap on
the outside the Jack Boots the bowler
hat
the single eyelash and eyeball on my on
the you know my shirt collar my
anyways or on the on the anyways it was
a very accurate
costume for Clockwork or A Clockwork
Orange
and no one knew who I was not one single
person in my high school knew who I was
and there were a couple teachers that
looked at me and said
how do you even know that movie
so
yeah
um but yeah no and more recently I
dressed as like Logan from Logan's Run
but I was Logan after he went to the new
you I just think that like Halloween is
not just an opportunity to you know uh
enjoy parties it's stress-free because
it doesn't involve family or travel
family and travel can be stressful
During certain holidays and you know
it's it's just non-stop parties and then
it's also enjoying horror movies and
getting to dress up like an adult
without judgment
and and so what's not to love about
Halloween you even theme parks make it a
month-long celebration everything from
Universal Horror Nights uh not scary
farm
Disneyland even does their their own
Halloween uh events so
I love Halloween you're not ever gonna
convince me and plus I I you know it's
I'll always discover new horror films I
haven't seen during Halloween
what are your top five go-to horror
films oh wow
well first off Night of the Living Dead
the Original 1968 George Romero is
absolutely one of my favorites
um frightened me beyond belief
that one uh John Carpenter's The Thing
horrific I saw that when I was a
teenager and it was the last time I ever
remember sleeping with the light on
because I was so terrified
uh the original Halloween the very first
Halloween with Jamie Lee Curtis
uh blew my mind
I would say alien
1979 Ridley Scott original alien is a
horror film that
um I mean yes people sort of put that in
the science fiction category but it uh
that's a horror film that holds up
to today
and uh
I got I got one more choice I got one
more
see now this is like a Sophie's choice
of Horror you've put me in this position
uh
I'm gonna say poultry Geist
because I love Lloyd Kaufman
it's weird it's more of a horror comedy
and uh it's it's about fast food
and then
um honorable mention to Evil Dead 2 and
Bruce Campbell in that movie
see I I got six out of it
which Halloween movies do you watch
every year Night of Living Dead I'll
watch at least once a year I used to own
so Night of the Living Dead I would
watch not just once a year I used to
when I was a kid I had a Super 8 sound
projector I had a full print of Night of
the Living Dead
okay and it was the way I found out like
because I'd only ever seen Night of the
Living Dead on some Chiller theater or
late night you know horror host so I'd
seen it then I didn't realize the movie
was cut when I finally got the Super 8
version all the kids in in the
neighborhood where I grew up in Royal
Oak Michigan we'd put a sheet on the
side of the garage and we'd get popcorn
and I would project Night of the Living
Dead you know full unedited there's like
full frontal nudity in that movie
there's gory stuff with guts and
intestines I mean it's a graphic movie
that George Romero really made for the
drive-in but uh at the time when I was a
kid didn't realize probably probably an
R-rated movie
and only got to see it because I had a
Super 8 projector and with money I saved
for my paper route got the complete
feature
but yeah that's one that um I like to
watch every year is is Night of the
Living Dead it's just
it's just it's so inspiring because it's
such a simple story
it's low budget
and most of the action I mean everybody
says the zombies are the villains in
that movie I think the zombies are a
catalyst
for all the tensions between the people
that are in the bordered up house that's
where the real conflict lies and that's
I think the Brilliance of George Romero
was to focus on that aspect
so that's that's a Halloween movie I
watch every year of course you know
Halloween without watching Halloween
it's just it just doesn't feel like
Halloween the John Carpenter original
with uh Jamie Lee Curtis is just I mean
just the sound of that score right you
just hear that score and it's fantastic
so
yeah those are those are those are ones
that I revisit can you recommend any
independent films that are Halloween
based
indie horror films yeah the very first
Evil Dead which I think when you watch
that film what I love about watching
that movie is just what little resources
Sam Raimi had to make the first Evil
Dead film you know he used like
stop-motion animation a lot of other
techniques one of my favorite techniques
that he used
and he used this not just for the first
evil dead but the second one as well
he called it a shaky cam
and it's sort of a it it's what he what
he did was he would take a camera he
would mount it on a two by four and run
with it or ride a bicycle
and it's sort of a the shaky cam is a
low budget version of a Steadicam
he literally just took a camera put it
in the center of the board right so it's
weighted it's in the center you have
like a seesaw the center of the Seesaw
is the camera and when you run with it
it gives it a smooth look so Sam Remy
used that for at least the early Evil
Dead films I'm not sure if he used it in
Evil Dead 3 but they would call it the
shaky camera and I just love that that
it's like well we've got no money we
can't afford to rent a Steadicam
you know but we're gonna just create one
and they used a two by four
as a kid what was your favorite
Halloween candy that you would always go
back to that house every year oh well
it's going to be a tie for me it's
malted milk balls because I love the
taste of malted milk and raisin heads
raisinets because
you know it's kind of the healthy candy
I you know it's got chocolates
but then recently I just found out
there's tons of sugar in raisins
and I was very disappointed to learn
this but I'm still I'm a raisinet's
popcorn and soda guy at the movies
because of that